it's winter in northern Sweden 200
kilometers north of the Arctic Circle on
Erland is crossing the frozen torna
river on her way to the village of Yuko
cr-v and the world's first and biggest
ice hotel the photographer has an
especially close relationship to this
place for years she supervised the
people who reshaped the hotel every
season and she was an ice artist herself
in 2013 she published a photo book about
the logic
for me the combination between the very
friendly and warm people and a really
cold environment of snow and ice that
combination that creates magic and I
decided to make a book about it
because I wanted to show the rest of the
world what I what I feel how much I feel
for this place each of the approximately
60 ice rooms has been individually
designed by artist light designers do
their part to set the stage in each room
everything here is made of ice or snow
except the mattresses and reindeer furs
on the beds the ice hotel is open from
December until mid-april and draws
50,000 visitors each year the
architecture is beautiful and it's very
cold but it's nice yeah I like it it was
really cool it's amazing our first time
here and you know in Taiwan we don't
have snow so we were so excited
it's one of my dream actually the day my
dreams come true
ice is gorgeous so it makes everything
look good
each year from October to December a
crew of about 100 builds the ice hotel
anew they use about 5,000 tons of ice
and snow artists from around the world
annually submit more than 100 designs
hoping to be given the task of creating
one of the rooms honor
Ellen had her chance in 2012
it's really really hard work
you don't work from 85 you work from
7:00 till 12:00 in the night time
usually so it's 24/7 and when you're
done with your room or your art than you
you're also done as an artist the
history of the Ice Hotel began in 1989
ice artists at a workshop built an igloo
to use as a bar after a night of
partying some of the guests slept in it
a success story was born now there are
many imitators around the world one
example is the Soros Niva igloo hotel in
northern Norway this is its 16th season
only a little newer is the line yo snow
village in Finland here even the
restaurant is made of ice
ice hotels are not limited to the Arctic
either some of these crystal palaces are
in the Alps or the Pyrenees the snow
hotel of Grande Valera in Andorra even
offers its guests a whirlpool in the
middle of the ice
but the Ice Hotel in yoga RV still has
the most guests one very important thing
is the Tana River of course it's very
clean water way yes I decide here it's
runs very very slowly in a very good way
so the ice will be of the best high
quality and also one of the most
important things we have always trying
to do something new and we put a lot of
effort on the art a night in the ice
hotel costs about 230 euros most
visitors spend only one night in a nice
room like Anna Ellen they spend the rest
of their stay in the area in typical
Swedish wooden houses in the evening
Anna seeks out the ice hotel's own
chapel for her it's this year's ice
hotel's most beautiful room
this is the hotel's ice bar the hotel
itself has kept on developing over the
past 25 years when people think of
Sweden the think of of Stockholm and the
ice hotel now there are so many tourists
coming to this area and that makes the
people can work here people can live
here so I think that's really really
important the temperature inside all the
ice rooms is five below zero Celsius but
that's cozy almost toasty compared to
the 20 below outside the walls of ice